hello everybody my name is markiplier
and tomorrow we're going to be doing a
charity livestream to raise money for my
friend's place which is a homeless youth
organization we've never done a
homelessness charity let alone a
homeless youth charity so this time
around we're gonna raise half a million
dollars together and how we're gonna do
that is I'm not gonna stop streaming
until we hit our goal of five hundred
thousand dollars I don't care how long
it takes I don't care how many
all-nighters I need to pull I'm just
gonna keep going until we get it and
hopefully it won't take more than the
weekend but if it does and that's just
the way it is so join me tomorrow 10:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time right here on
YouTube and we'll have a lot of fun
together over the weekend now I don't
expect anybody to stay up with me I want
to be very clear about that I don't
expect anybody to pull an all weekender
with me I'm gonna do this and you can go
to sleep and you can wake up and you can
join me and guess what I'll probably
still be there I didn't realize how big
of a problem it was until I started
reading the statistics I knew that it
was a problem across the nation I was
aware of it but it was all background
problem and when you start to read the
statistics it's almost frightening in a
way because of kids under the age of 18
every year youth homelessness affects
between 1.6 and 1.7 million kids every
year and the statistics get worse from
there the more you read each year about
a hundred thousand kids become victims
of commercial sexual exploitation that
number is terrifying and forty percent
of the runaway and homeless youth
populations actually come from the LGBTQ
community which is weird considering
that's ten percent of the general
population
forty percent of runaway and homeless
youth are from the lgbtq+ community and
25 percent of the homeless youth
population
you know they suffer from some form of
serious mental illness like it already
is unbelievably hard to get help if
you're homeless but it can be impossible
if you're already suffering from some
mental illness the more I read about it
the more I just realized that I had to
something about it and I could do
something about it so that's why we're
gonna be doing a charity stream tomorrow
and that's why we're just not gonna stop
until we hit our goal this organization
does great work it's not the only
homeless charity out there it's not the
only youth homeless charity out there
but they are extremely highly rated and
their mission is very tangible it gives
direct help like of those big scary
statistical numbers they've helped 1418
homeless youth in Los Angeles today and
that may seem like a small amount but
that's one third of the homeless
population homeless youth population in
LA if we can help them out they can get
closer to helping everybody join me
tomorrow 10:00 a.m. for the longest live
stream I've ever done to help raise
money for my friends place we're also
selling merch on markiplier comm all
proceeds go to my friend's place as well
but most of it will be through tilta phi
i'll provide a link in the description
of the livestream and if I have it set
up at the time it will be in the
description down below right here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you at the live
stream bye-bye